>> Welcome Yoshua, to
Microsoft and in Redmond.
You've been here as part
of our Microsoft AI's
distinguished lecture series and
gave a fabulous talk yesterday.
>> Thank you.
>> To a standing
room only crowd,
here and spent time with
our researchers and
engineers and I want to thank
you for taking
this opportunity to share
some of your insights
with a broader community.
So we're here in part because of
the role that you've played as
an amazing leading figure in
a real transformation that
deep learning has enabled in
the last 5-10 years
and you think
about the capabilities that
computers now have from,
speech recognition, speech
generation, image analysis,
even real-time translation
from one language to another.
There's a whole
generation of people
growing up who think that
you can pick up a phone,
say something and something
magical will happens
most of the time.
10 years ago that
was inconceivable
and you must be proud,
excited, exhilarated by this.
But you've also, this is not
something that you've
taken up recently,
you've been in the field
for a number of years.
I did the wrong math yesterday,
and said 25 years but you
corrected me and
said it's 30 years.
Can you say a little bit
about what's
motivated you over the years
to continue to think about,
a human intelligence,
machine intelligence and
how we can leverage
insights from both of those?
>> Right, so, when I read
these first neural net papers
around 1985, 1986, it
was passion, I mean,
like I didn't know what to
do for my grad studies.
Suddenly I knew.
>> So these are the Rumelhart,
McClelland, and early papers
and Geoff Hinton and
somethings like that.
>> So Geoff Hinton was
a huge inspiration for me,
and, yeah, the whole
connectionist groom.
The PDP book was my Bible.
>> The two volumes?
>> The two volumes. Yes, yes.
One the reasons I
was attracted beyond
the AI and my adolescent
interest for science fiction,
was the idea that by studying
this field not only we'll
get a better understanding of
intelligence for
building machines
that could be useful for humans.
>> Right.
>> But also will
help us to understand
our own intelligence.
As as intelligence
is something so
central to what humans means.
>> You focus mostly on
the former of those?
>> Yeah.
>> You still have
a deep passion for the latter?
>> Yeah. I mean obviously
I had to make a choice.
I was more of a nerd.
Then somebody,
attracted to psychology
and things like this.
But over the years,
probably again
following the inspiration
from Geoff Hinton,
I've always kept close proximity
to neuroscientists,
cognitive scientists.
As you may know,
we have set up this program,
Seefar program,
which brings together
AI machine learning
researchers with
neuroscientists
and kind sciences.
>> Can you share a little bit
about your thesis?
Because in many ways it bears
at least a surface
level resemblance
to many of the things
that are going on today.
>> Sure.
So in my thesis,
which I started in 1986,
actually, that was
the master's thesis
and then I did PhD.
In Canada, we do masters and PhD
so and I finished in 1991.
I was, so during
this five years I was working on
speech recognition using
Recurrent Neural Nets
with a sort of
convolutional architecture,
was before modern
architectures, obviously.
Any Probabilistic Models,
Hidden Markov models,
with the neural and
the probabilistic pieces
being integrated,
that was my main contribution,
how to train
these things properly.
It gave me a lot of hands-on
experience with
the difficulties of
training neural nets,
and in particular,
I stumbled upon the difficulties
or training recurrent nets on
long sequences and
a few years later,
I published a number
of papers on
that subject which became
very, very well cited.
>> Good.
So in the last 10 years,
we've really seen
a transformation of some
of those ideas and
roots take place.
What do you think
the top two or three things,
are either technical or
social that have enabled that?
>> That have?
>> Enabled the the amazing
revolution that we've seen in
the last decade or
so in deep learning.
>> Well, these things
have been said
before by many people.
Of course there's
a alignment of planets
and its its been technical
progress on the algorithms,
the amount of data,
the computing power.
If we focus on the algorithms,
there is, of course,
what gave them the name
Deep Learning Depth,
which has been an intense
subject of study from
the beginning and of interests,
why would it help,
and this idea that I
continue pushing today,
that what we should be striving
for our machines that discover
better representations,
that are more and more abstract.
The other idea that we had
at the beginning was that,
by stacking these layers
on top of each other,
we build more complex
obstructions on top
of simpler ones.
So that's a very central thing,
and now we understand
it better mathematically,
theoretically.
But there were a few
really important,
little technical things that
completely changed the way
we are approaching
applications in
our success in many cases.
Such as, the use of
rectifiers, the ReLu and so on.
Actually, my student
Ziegler row and I,
were the first to
show that, hey,
if you use these piece
wise linear networks,
you can really train
deep nets whereas,
if you had the hyperbolic
tangent it didn't work.
So we don't yet,
and just that we don't
have a good theory
to understand that yet.
This was 2010.
>> So still lots
of work to be done?
>> Yeah, yeah. Then I
would say another
great contribution
to today's success
for many models,
not for computer vision but
more on the language side,
is the use of
attention mechanisms.
As you said there's been crucial
for machine translation
for example,
but it's now used
everywhere we went to handle
more complicated
data structures then
simple images or sequences.
So that's interesting
because it's changing,
these things are really
changing the face of
neural nets as I
was using them in
the late 80s, during my PhD.
They used to be pattern
recognition machines and
the first successes with
speech recognition for example
and then with object
recognition in images,
you're really focused on
this pattern
recognition ability.
But if you look at what
people are doing now
and for example applications in
natural length like machine
reading comprehension
and even in
complicated models that
involve reinforcement
learning or
memory these notions of
attention become
really, really useful.
>> Okay. You shared,
yesterday with us some of
your insights about moving
from the remarkable
progress we've made
in pattern recognition too
much higher level cognitive
capabilities in large part by
abstraction and talked
about a couple of
what are essentially priors
that one can use to
constrain what it is that
an agent acting in the world
would need to learn.
Can you share some of
those broad ideas
with the audience?
>> Sure, absolutely.
So first of all,
I think the idea
that machine learning
is built by combining
the right priors and of course
you know bringing the data
on top of that is
something that is not
sufficiently appreciated.
Some people think that,
we got this magical
universal recipe
that's going to solve
all of our problems.
No, unfortunately.
There is this the dream of
Tabula Rasa machine learning but
it just doesn't
make much sense and
instead what we're doing in
practice is coming up with
sometimes very
domain specific and
hopefully more
general constraints
or a priority or assumption
that help structure
the models so that they will
generalize very very well.
In fact, depth itself is
an example of things like that.
What I talked about
yesterday are priors
that we can put in
the architecture,
the training framework
that hopefully
help the learners mostly
unsupervised but it
could be also supervised or
reinforcement learning
to discover
better representations
and better means that in
the represented space you
could hopefully
predict more easily,
those predictions could
involve very few variables
so this is the
consciousness prior or
these variables would correspond
closely to aspects of
the world that can be
controlled by the agent.
So these are the kinds of ideas
that I'm exploring these days.
>> Again, to pop
up a level a bit,
the goal of a lot of
this work is really
to enable machines to come from
some of the very simple
and perceptual tasks
that they do very well at now to
achieving the level of
higher level abstraction in
common sense that even toddlers.
>> Yeah, we are far from
building machines that have
the learning capability
of toddlers.
We can do a lot of
engineering to solve
specific problems and
bring in tons of data
and do a lot better
than toddlers or
sometimes even
better than adults,
but toddlers are still hugely
better at quickly
learning new tasks,
quickly learning language which
is one of the things
I'm interested
in and we don't know
how to manage that.
So, one thing that
I think we need
to pay more attention
to is some of
the older ideas from AI and
cognitive science which
have been sort of forgotten
with all this
modern deep learning
and we need to find
a way to augment
the deep learning concepts
that have been very successful
with some of the objectives
that the eye has set
itself to solve without
losing all of the advantages
of better generalization and
so on capturing what looks like
intuition which current
deep learning is giving us.
>> So do you think that
involves a combination of
neural and symbolic
architectures
or taking ideas
from each of those?
What do you think of
the architecture of [inaudible].
>> There was
a popular set of papers,
I mean interests
in the 90s trying
to marry the neural with the
symbolic and there was like
workshops and
conferences and so on.
It didn't really
work. I think maybe
the mistake was to try to
build some sort of hybrid.
Whereas, I'm thinking more
about hybrid at
a more abstract level
where we take
the concepts that have
the principles have
worked well in one case
and in the other case
and how do we build
architectures that
combine these advantages,
that for example introduce
in things like neural nets,
the notion of indirect reference
which is central to
symbolic processing.
It's quite feasible
to design architectures
that have this.
Is just that people haven't
explored that very much.
>> So when you say
indirect reference,
you mean things like no sense of
objects and name
and events, right?
>> Yeah. So, names right?
So, a name is something
you can reuse in
different contexts and
that you can assign values,
you can do computation
on the name itself.
>> Right, okay.
>> So once you bring
the notion of name in
the neural net world it becomes
just something we're familiar
with like embeddings,
because we want
to be able to name
a combinatorially
large set of things.
So now we see this kind
of marriage coming.
>> Good. You're making
initial strides in
this area and it seems like
a really difficult challenge,
partly because we
don't know what
the objective
functions are partly
because or they're distributed
over time in many scenarios.
Can you just speak a little,
give folks a glimmer
of what the future
might hold in that area?
>> Sure. So what we're trying to
do is also move machine learning
away from the raw perceptual
space where all of
our current training
objectives are located
like likelihood or
even the gan objectives.
They're all like in pixel space.
Instead, if you consider
what humans value,
how humans plan, how
we check that our predictions
are good and what kind of
predictions we're making,
it's all happening in
this abstract space.
We don't make t to t plus
one predictions and
unfold all of this.
Like directly predict
things in some vague future
and we do it in
this very abstract space
which doesn't need to
describe every pixel.
So this endeavor with,
for example the
consciousness prior is
trying to design or presentation
learning mechanisms that where
the objective function
is defined in
that space and that could be
used for example in
reinforcement learning
where planning or unfolding into
the future doesn't need to be
happening in like playing
a movie in your head.
That's not what's happening in
people's mind but
rather something
abstract that can
refer to only some,
only needs to refer
to some aspects of
the world and not every
little detail of it.
>> Okay. So, is work for
example in Program Induction,
central to these ideas or was
that a different
way of approaching
some of these you know
the ability to act in the world,
understand the consequences
of your actions,
predict what might happen
>> So, I think in
Program Induction there is
an approach in which
we're working purely
syntactically which like we're
doing with our
current deep learning,
where we're modeling
sequences of characters that
somehow do correspond to
programs and I don't believe
this is going to work.
I think for program induction
and as well for general AI,
what we need is grounded
language learning.
In other words that
the learner figures
out at the same time as it's
learning the language
like that the symbols
that are being manipulated
is learning what they refer to.
In the case of
Program Induction that would
be what the computation
corresponds to
and then learns
to somehow reason
and act with that knowledge.
In general language learning,
I think this is
something that's been
discussed for many years and I
see more and more papers
in that direction.
I'm very encouraged
by that directions
from the community and I
want to push that as well.
>> I have a few general
questions that I want to pop to,
I mean thank you
for sharing some of
the insights about how
you got into this area,
your decade long pursuit
and understanding how
people learn using
inspirations from that
to support the development
of more intelligent machines.
But I want to focus on
a couple of other things.
So one would be you
right now in Montreal
as a Professor at
the University of Montreal,
as the head of the MILA
or broader organization,
as an important member
in this community,
I have seen lots of students
and lots of collaborators.
Is there any advice
that you can offer to
new people who are interested in
the field both at
a technical level,
so maybe people who'll
develop the next algorithms,
but also people who are thinking
about how to use some of
the insights shape insights
for their problems.
>> So, first of all,
there's a lot of information
about AI machine learning,
deep learning, personal learning
available out there for free.
I often get, undergrad coming to
me from poor countries even,
who got a lot of their
information from the Internet.
There's so many things,
tutorials, videos,
papers of course, everything is
an archive in
our field, it's amazing.
And libraries, open source code,
so there's a lot of opportunity
to learn by yourself,
and if you can
afford a GPU card,
even like a cheap one,
you can actually do quite a lot.
In terms of learning,
you won't be able to
compete in some of
these harder benchmarks,
you can learn a lot.
You can understand how
new net training is happening.
So there's a lot that an
individual who's motivated,
and has basics in
computer science and math,
can actually learn
by themselves.
That being said, I see
an amazing progression of,
say, some of
those students who are
coming to labs like mine,
and after six months, a year,
or two years of
working in a group,
and there's this synergy
that happens in the learning,
the presence of people
who know more than you,
environments in which
you can speak freely,
you can express your ideas
and not feel judged.
>> Right.
>> I think, transform
these people
into researchers very quickly,
and so, if you have a chance
to go in an existing group,
I think it could be
a big step in your learning.
So, this is why students
do grad studies.
I know these days,
it might be tempting for
many people to directly go
from undergrad or masters
level training, to industry.
But you don't necessarily
get that if you're
going to especially,
become an engineer who
applies these things.
So, depending on
where you want to go,
I think it's something
to think about.
>> That sounds like
foundational skills,
hands-on practice for
people who are more,
maybe researching client,
even being part of a larger,
intellectual and open
and sharing community.
>> And reading.
>> Reading. Okay.
>> Reading. I mean
this is not new.
Any scientists will tell you.
Right? You can't even
stay on top of
your science if you don't
read at least 20 percent
of your time.
In our field,
things are moving so fast.
I can't keep up with everything
that's being written obviously.
So, this is a social network,
I get to know what
to read because I
talk to other people
and I tell them,
"I read this and
you should read it",
and some of that happens online.
So, reading and getting
inspiration like reading groups,
in order to have
guidance about what to
read, is really important.
There are nice things
like OpenReview.net
>> Right.
>> Where, people in our field
in the SCLR community
submit their papers,
and then anyone can comment,
and you can read
the reviews online.
This is amazing. This is great.
It allows for
more participation,
and allows for
people to see how the
process of submitting
papers and reviewing,
and analyzing what's going on,
and also just knowing, okay,
I probably don't
want to read this,
or I didn't expect
this I should read it.
You don't need to read
the whole paper to
get a sense of what's in there.
>> You also learn a lot by
people's comments on papers.
>> Yes.
>> It's really interesting
to see some of that in
the OpenReview comments.
>> And you can have
anonymous comments so that.
>> For better or worse.
There are positives
and negatives.
>> Reflecting about
the changes that have
happened in the last
decade to support
some real advancements in
machine learning and AI,
one of the things you
didn't mention that
I think is really
important and that
you've spent a lot of
your energy supporting
is a really open,
agile and collaborative
environment
whether it's through
tools with Theano.
Through the book, that you
and Ian Goodfellow
and Aaron Courville
published that is one of
the best sellers on Amazon
but also more importantly,
the chapters are
available for anybody.
>> Yeah, for free.
>> To read without carrying
necessarily the book
around to new conferences
to focus on
representation learning,
the OpenReview process even
publishing early in
archive all of those have
created I think a new energy in
AI and machine learning
that wasn't there before.
Can you comment on how?
>> I'm not the only one there,
it's a community thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Actually you
forgot one thing,
in the late 90s,
I perceived it in the revolt of
the machine learning
journal board
that led to
the creation of GMLR,
which is now
the flagship journal.
>> So, you've always
had this revel streak.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Maybe, open
collaborative community.
>> Yes, that's right.
>> That has led to
a lot of the both to
the insights but also perhaps to
a frenetic and
unmaintainable pace so, yeah.
>> There are good sides
and bad sides here.
>> Yeah.
>> I think overall,
it's helping
the progress of science.
>> Right.
>> It's helping
making science more
accessible as well,
which is something I care about.
So some of what you're
talking about is
associated with a sense of
responsibility that I think,
Scientists should have and
especially as they
mature in their career.
We can give back and
the things that matter are not
just how many papers
we published.
>> That's hard sometimes for
a young graduate student looking
for a position to appreciate.
>> Yeah.
>> So, let me ask a final
question that builds on that so,
it's clear now that AI is out of
its academic box and really
having a profound impact on
many aspects of society
you hear about it
in all sorts of things
ranging from fake news
to issues of fairness,
accountability, and
transparency and ethics.
Do you have any insights
about how we as
a research community,
an intellectual community can
help shape those outcomes
for the better?
>> I think there
are many ways in
which researchers in
this field can have
a positive contribution to
the social impact and
the ethical aspects and how,
what we call AI for good,
how AI could be used for
the good of humanity in general.
I see it's amazing.
A very rapid increase
in the interest in
these questions over the last
12 months even two years.
One of the aspects
that I'm thinking
more about these days is
how we should try to
shift the kinds of
machine learning problems
on which we work towards,
like object
recognition on ImageNet
towards problems that could
have a big positive impact in
the world and
especially problems
that companies traditionally
are not really interested
in because there may not
be any profit in the short term.
Like humanitarian applications.
So, that's something I've
been thinking about and how
we could help
the poorest countries
with technology with machine
learning with our skills.
How we could help the people in
those countries
learn those skills
so that they can
help themselves.
I think there's a lot that
could be done and because
these problems are not
necessarily for profit,
it would be easier
for companies,
the big IT companies to
actually collaborate on
these questions than
the traditional applications
where they're really
competing against each other.
>> So, let's close on
that call to action,
for the machine learning and AI
community to not just continue
our technical excellence,
but understand how we can really
shape people and society
which is certainly one
of our passions here.
>> Thank you very much Susan.
>> Thank you so much for
your visit and for
this wonderful talk.
>> My pleasure.
>> Thanks Yoshua.